you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game alrighty let's try c4 that's
black gonna do symmetrical okay let's
get the night out first
copycat variation no okay
changing it up a little bit
um how about alright let's go it's being
cut up
posing LightSquared bishop s' get some
standard moves in and I think I'm gonna
hold off on playing d4 straightaway
let's go for something different
let's try b3 first I'm going to retain
some options with my Center pawns forgot
I could highlight WAMP line
double fiend keto what's black going to
do with the deep on
they'd see 6d 6d v it is okay so I think
we first take I don't want to see I want
to see what how block captures first
it's a pond I go this may be on any move
I go this d4 yeah I think just d4
straightaway yeah let's get D foreign
Knight takes Bishop takes Bishop f6 is
this happening soon
yeah well rook c1 I have to be accurate
here on Queen d2 on Queen d2 knight c6
and then if I'm capturing there's Queen
takes Bishop takes Bishop takes rook I
think I have to play rook see one here
and then Bishop takes Knight I could
recapture and beyond the rook this is a
very important detail
one two three defenders and three
attackers I'm okay on d4 on pond takes
what am i doing on the recapture
let's see Bishop takes Bishop yeah I
think I just go with the bishop I wanna
I wanna get rid of this Bishop on f6
yeah let's do that and another thing is
I don't want to be too quick to give up
my light-square bishop with the Queen
still on the board the Queen's are off
the board I think this is just going to
happen and yeah so let's let's take with
the Queen and in this endgame on just a
look a little bit better developed still
now plying and another thing that I'm
looking forward to is that my King is a
little bit improved I already have a
flight square so let's see if I could
try and press a little bit there's not
too much to assess assess structurally
it's just a slight time advantage in the
position I don't have to react to that
it's not threatening rip takes
night-night c6 Knight b5 in to c7 this
night I'll probably try to circle into
c5 I could get the Knights off but
that's a pretty dry ending who then c6
Knight takes rook takes rook d2
I'll have anything how about this my
nights not gonna budge just gonna play
III Knight d7 rook c7 or that okay well
let's go here stop any Knight be for a
knight c5 I could give him a kick
I'm just preparing to double here like
still needs a flight square a knight on
b5 can be a bit of a pest to black
because he cannot be easily kicked with
a six now that the night is on a6 slight
time advantage for my opponent
just preparing to double on the C file
structure
maybe this could uh well maybe this
slight edge again can translate into
something like maybe I net myself upon
here the a pond definitely taking with
the peace and okay actually now I have
rook a for you know let's go for yeah
let's go in I was pausing there for a
moment because I'm anticipating my
nights gonna be dislodged but when he
retreats here he's at least striking at
this and stopping rook to d2 from the f3
square should i improve my king are my
knight maybe it's time to move my knight
the Knights well
I feel like I want to not even allow my
night to be kicked I'm gonna play f4
and my night I'll be there to stop
Brooksie - and maybe I could start
grabbing some space on the kingside I
think whenever I try to go after this
guy the rook is going to get active over
here right around the two-minute mark
for black can't really get this in so
easily also without the f-pawn around
the king is completely cut off could
also look for improvements like King f3
yeah let's go King out three right now
and to try to maybe weave a mate with f5
and if I take here yeah that's what
they're shooting for huh but what if I
first moved my king now isn't this a
threat at some point
just trying to get my king to safer
ground
mmm maybe better was to immediately
start pushing my pawns yeah I should
probably do that after after this move
let's let's just get running with these
pawns these might fall but it's it's
gonna be a big race I should get these
guys going really soon really really
soon and I don't care so much about this
guy drive time to maybe pick up the beep
on a minute 15 I'm just gonna get
pushing I think just having one past
pawn will be enough
no tricky stuff there is a check here
but I have this it's my only legal move
this apon should be pretty fast combined
with the night I mean if he's over here
he's kind of out of play we still need
to get this guy before he becomes a
passed pawn it's my only move easy
decision
okay um I guess here we're gonna go for
some perpetual
oh boy that's tricky forty seconds
[Music]
maybe this is the best that I could do
king b3 rook check you know what I'm
gonna go for the draw here I think black
is going to be there in time yeah I'll
accept the drum whoops didn't mean to
hit that
yeah I think I had to go for that I
think it was just way too risky too
for more like here here and then this
allowing this check and
[Music]
you know I was thinking it would have to
go the other way where my king was
forced back here and black gets this
pawn right here let's see yeah maybe I
could have played
laid 2c3 like I did and then in this
position instead of king up
maybe I go here yeah and then here for
some reason I was thinking that blacks
gonna get the pun and my Kings gonna be
forced to back but after this now I'm on
move there's no check but I could very
easily fall for me
a five and I get made
and that's what I was intending to do
just start running with upon I think
objectively we'll have a look at it with
the computer but yeah I think I think it
was the right decision to go for a drunk
maybe I could have instead of f4 maybe I
could have no I still I still like f4
just to secure my night but as soon as
this night move I think right now just
get on with these moves I'm off upon
let's let's say just set it into motion
going here I just run into a bunch of
different checks you know here stabilize
stabilize my night and then get on with
a for B B for a 5 yeah I should have run
it like that
as far as the opening is concerned let
me let me just bring up the analysis for
starters okay here we go this is where I
want it to be so it was a pretty dry
opening symmetrical English no imbalance
with the structure or piecewise
my slight lead in development eventually
translated into winning up on let's see
how maybe black could have avoided that
think I don't think that there's really
much of an issue takes takes let's go
out the night D seven instead of Bishop
f6 rook c1 yeah
just to highlight the issue with Queen
d2 I think at least I thought the issue
if that would have been night here
or excuse me not not night there but
okay yeah night night c6 and now if I
make this capture then there's Queen
takes Queen and then Bishop takes rook
I just want to get out of the line of
fire this is after all a purposeful file
open or half open rook belongs there
he's now out of harm's way
so rook c1
shop yeah it's just even okay just a
nibble of an advantage here for white
hmm yeah I do have a little bit of
something how could I have converted
that ending better and it wants to
activate a rook here III can't be bad
though just stabilizing the night hmm
guess it's okay
they'd a six I'm just preparing to
double and now I have a win Wow
I've knight c6 instead of doubling
knight c6 with the threat of going into
e7
ah it's just a game ender so natural and
moveright
just preparing to double and this is
already game over
wherever the rook goes doesn't matter
I'm still going into e7 and that's it we
don't we don't reach move well it's as
far as move 20 I had a tactical shot
knight c6 here okay I doubled and now
it's back to same evaluation okay so I
we both we both missed it at that
tactical shot g6 and now I'm picking up
a pond so I guess what black has to do
is maybe Knight c5 yeah Knight c5 is
better here you know okay so from this
point once I'm up the pond how could I
have better converted this okay it likes
f4 securing the knight not allowing this
second rank check to hit so easily and
the other thing what happened in the
game it was the rut got to c1 and then
he circled around like this so my king
should really just stick around to
defend h2 and this is maybe two
I don't know to how to describe it
you know to to routine a move you know
it's an ending you move the king towards
the center just like when my rook was
here and the rook went over I went with
the routine move like double and I had
that tactical shot 9 c6 suggests rook b7
here but I could probably get on with a
4 here I mean it's a pretty significant
advantage something close to 2 yeah it's
just a really good rook a really good
night and there isn't going to be any
mating net yeah I mean I'm even I'm
actually a bit more vulnerable on f3
than I am on g2
and how I played at King f3 if I'm
grabbing this pawn and I think I'm I
thought at least I would be lost I guess
there's a way that I could force a
knight exchange oh this is interesting
this is an interesting point on rook
Seto I thought that this mate would be
unavoidable but I have this check and
after King f7 I have Knight g5 oh that's
a nice maneuver to be familiar with I
can force the knight exchange now that's
that's why I like going over these games
these are the different tactical things
that you overlook
okay okay so I don't have to really be
too concerned about that may threaten f2
because of this this check and then
Knight g5 move that's cool how I played
it King e 2 starts to get a little bit
tricky a 4 I'm dropping upon back and
what about this final position what does
it want to do here
it wants to just scoop up this pawn
mm-hmm
I was more focused right around this
point at least with trying to get some
kind of a passed pawn on the A or B file
instead of grabbing this pawn ok before
and what about this final position was
it the right decision to just take the
draw it does read it as even king c3
Knight back to e4 and if I'm to try for
something like King b3
d3 king c4 rook takes pawn okay I'm
still I'm still better but yeah it's
still tight yeah it's still tight here
wants to follow up with King b5 at
there's poor calculation on my part
because again I was thinking that I'm
gonna drop this pawn and I would have to
come back here the variation that I was
looking at was I believe after check
King c4 Knight check not sure what
exactly I was thinking maybe at this
point if I go trying to get this right
let's see after this check
after this check I thought that if if I
wanted to avoid the for this back and
forth check that I would have to go here
and then there's this check and then I
would have to go back that's what the
night on this square but I could go to
b3 when the night is on e4 and it's a
much different story my King isn't my
king wouldn't be cut off if I'm going to
be three
when the night is on e4 okay there's a
little bit confusing for me yeah we
ended it's a little draw by perpetual
check or threefold repetition I don't
know if I have had that happen before in
one of the games that I've recorded I
don't like doing that
hey I want to win and sometimes it's a
it's to a fault I play on and I'm
objectively worse but it's I still had a
little bit of a thing to go for in this
ending and game but some interesting
tactics missed along the way I like I
like that grabbing on e6 and being able
to parry the the main threat with the
check and then Knight to g5 that's a
it's a nice resource to be familiar with
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this game in the comment
section below and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you
[Music]